bonsoir jean marc civette merci d'être
avec nous la pire performance
trimestrielle de l'économie depuis la
fin de la seconde guerre mondiale rien
que ça qu'elle est jean marc sylvestre
votre réaction
écoutez madame ma réaction c'est je suis
effectivement atterré par l'ampleur des
dégâts que provoque cette crise et dans
le monde entier alors sur la france on a
des chiffres qui ont été avancés par la
bande que de france aujourd'hui à titre
provisoire mais ils correspondent à la
réalité c'est que nous avons perdu en
gros si % de pipe par rapport à l'année
dernière sur la même période pour le
premier trimestre et que nous perdons en
gros à peu près à et demi pour cent à
chaque quinze jours de confinement ça
veut dire que si on est encore confiné
pendant tout le mois d'avril et bien on
va on va avoisiner presque les 10% de
récession en termes annuels à partir du
mois prochain
donc c'est absolument colossal alors ça
a deux particularités qu'il faut pas
oublier c'est que la première c'est que
ces mondial c'est que pour la première
fois toute l'économie mondiale s'est
arrêté au même moment pratiquement parce
que tous les moteurs de l'économie sont
arrêtés vous n'avez pas de consommation
les moteurs de l'économie c'est quoi
c'est la consommation c'est
l'investissement et c'est l'exportation
la consommation s'est arrêté évidemment
parce que les gens ne consomment plus
ils restent confinés chez eux et puis
ils vont au minimum c'est-à-dire
l'agroalimentaire et puis les questions
de sécurité
les investissements ont tous été arrêtés
et ont tous été reportée regarder ce qui
se passe dans l'aéronautique on ne
l'achète plus l'avion n'achète plus de
l'aude dans l'automobile dans la
construction
bon et puis le commerce extérieur il est
également planté dans les ports dans les
européens plus un seul avion dans l'air
donc c'est c'est une véritable
catastrophe dans la mesure où le monde
entier hérité mais la deuxième
conséquence la deuxième chose que vous
avez c'est que c'est ce choix là et est
imputable finalement au choix de
confinement et c'est quoi c'est qu'on a
voulu protéger les vies humaines
on a voulu protéger les vies humaines et
pour protéger les vies humaines
eh bien on a essayé de ralentir la
circulation du
deux virus et pour ralentir la
circulation des côtes du virus on a
appris la responsabilité de ralentir
l'économie
c'est la première fois dans le monde et
c'est assez c'est positif si vous voulez
comme comme réaction parce que l'or lors
des pandémies précédentes on s'était pas
très beaucoup préoccuper des dés de
protéger les vies humaines on essayait
de protéger finalement l' équilibre
global de ces moments des épidémies de
variole ou de rougeole pour tes
terrifiant la peste noire et même le
sida vous savez le sida il a fait 38
millions de morts dans le monde
eh bien on n'en est pas là avec avec le
grenat pyrrhus
donc je sais ça c'est important et puis
l'autre chose qu'il faut qu'il faut
souligner c'est que effectivement c'est
une collaboration du monde entier dont
on va avoir besoin
jean-marc lillers évidemment la question
que tout le monde se pose est ce que on
va pouvoir se relever de ça et au final
qui va payer
alors on va pouvoir se relever de ça si
ça ne dure pas très longtemps mais yahia
il ya quand même un point positif de
drogue dans tout ça c'est que
contrairement aux autres crise
économique vous parliez de la crise des
subprimes en 2008 2009
on peut parler de la deuxième guerre
mondiale en 1940 contrairement à ces
crises là où on a perdu et il n'y a pas
eu de destruction d'actifs
les entreprises ne sont pas démoli elles
sont à l'arrêt 1
il suffit de faire repartir le le moteur
de tourner la clé
et ça repart l'offre potentiellement
elle peut être pas existé les usines
chinoises et j procès des juges nommés
mais j'en activ'air pardonnez moi je
voudrais vous couper là dessus parce que
vous dites il suffit de voir un de
rallumer le moteur grâce à ça va pour
les grandes entreprises peut-être mais
mais les pme
est ce que vraiment le chômage partiel
peut les sauver vous réellement il y
aura des faillites le chômage partiel
permet à l'entreprise de rester en
l'état de fonctionner c'est à dire car
pas de rupture de contrat de travail
c'est à dire que demain et bien les
salariés reviennent au travail
retrouvent leur job ils retrouvent leur
poste etc
mais ça faut pas que ça dure trop
longtemps parce que évidemment le
chômage partiel cela coûte très très
cher à la collectivité donc ça peut
éventuellement redémarrer ça peut même
redémarrer très vite mais un il faut pas
que ça dure trop longtemps parce que si
ça dure trop longtemps on va casser
évidemment le tissu des pme on va aussi
casser les grandes entreprises regardez
les risques pour air france aujourd'hui
airbus l'automobile par exemple on a
cassé ces entreprises là déjà en 2008
2009 on a mis dix ans à l'aller à
l'heure alors remonter donc il faut pas
que ça dure trop longtemps
deuxièmement il faut que les procédures
de déconfinement c'est à dire de sortir
de deux sorties de cet immobilisme se
fasse dans des conditions de sécurité
sanitaire parce qu'on nous n'oubliez pas
que l'arrêt vraies raisons profondes
c'est l'inquiétude au niveau de la santé
c'est que vous avez cette épée de
damoclès sur sur la tête et il faut
absolument l'éliminer donc il faut
trouver les conditions de sécurité tout
ce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
c'était évidemment ce qu'il faut mettre
en oeuvre et renforcé quand renforcer le
confinement renforcer les gestes qu'ils
de protection renforcée le masque
renforcer évidemment aussi tout tout la
traçabilité de façon à pouvoir
reconnaître ceux qui sont malades de
ceux qui ne sont pas malades ou de ceux
qui ont été malades et qui sont
immunisés c'est comme cela
progressivement qu'on sortira en terme
de sécurité et six cas de la sécurité y
aura de la confiance et s'il ya de la
confiance est bien la machine économique
repartira quand on sait que la dette est
déjà de 100% du pib
je vous repose la question
qui va payer au final est-ce que c'est
l'état qui va continuer à emprunter ou
finalement c'est vous et moi avec nos
impôts
écouter de toute façon c'est vous et moi
qui paieront au final que ce soit avec
des impôts
que ce soit avec des hausses de prix ou
avec de l'inflation parce que il faudra
bien qu'il y ait un rééquilibrage
mais tu ça ça peut s'étaler dans le
temps tout ça ça peut aussi entraîner
des modifications structurelles avec
peut-être plus de productivité plus de
rentabilité de façon à ce qu'on puisse
rembourser
et tout ça je j'entendais les
difficultés que peut avoir l'europe
on oublie très souvent que l'europe
allait doter de la banque centrale
européenne et que c'est aujourd'hui la
banque centrale européenne qui assure la
mutualisation de tout ça au sein de
l'europe avec des avec des des dotations
en liquidités qui sont considérables
secteur dont on parle pas mais qui est
totalement sécurisée aujourd'hui les
grands en europe grâce à la banque
centrale et rance au mécanisme européen
c'est le secteur de la banque
vous n'avez pas une banque aujourd'hui
qu'ils soient en état de risques ou de
fragilité cd pas le cas en 2008
en 2008 on a bien failli un peu comme
lehman brothers avoir des problèmes de
ce côté là donc vous à vous avez quand
même une mécanique financière qui peut
absorber tout ça mais il est évident que
la vie d'après sera pas exactement comme
celle de la vie d'avant ce panier
d'europe justement et chacun aujourd'hui
de la réunion démunis des finances est
ce que cette action conjointe de l'union
européenne est ce qu'elle est nécessaire
et est ce qu'elle va voir le jour parce
que ça me semble compliqué manifestement
les nécessaires ce qui est très
compliqué c'est de mettre en place un
produit financier qui s'appelait le qui
s'appellerait leur bond ou le koro la
bonde c'est un produit dont certains
courants politiques rêvent depuis très
longtemps mais c'est un produit qui
oblige les gens qui ont de l'argent à
payer pour les gens qui n'en n'ont pas
dans un espace dont de mutualité il faut
qui est quand même un deal dans tout ça
et moi je comprends parfaitement
quelque part les allemands les
scandinaves que j'ai à dire bah tu vas
quand même pas on a on a nos propres
problèmes on viendrait à la france
demande et le reggae problème italien je
crois qu on sait pas se précipiter en
italie pour pour les aider et les
italiens d'ailleurs s'en souviennent
donc ce problème de solidarité mutualité
il a d'autre moyen que le corps avant de
passer je parlais de la banque centrale
européenne la banque centrale européenne
fait de la mutualisation
elle en fait tous les jours et elle elle
distribue des liquidités aff de façon
aspects du système fonctionne et vous
avez d'autres mécanismes de financement
qui fonctionne et qui vont fonctionner
sans parler de l'effort personnel qui
seront faites par les différents
gouvernements les efforts qui ont été
faits par les différents gouvernements
l'espagne et alvin à la censure des
efforts qui sont colossaux donc on aura
sans doute une réunion après ou savoir
comment on se répartit les factures et
vous savez c'est comme dans une
copropriété
c'est pas facile hein il faut mais ça
demandera sans doute du temps mais si on
veut rester en copropriété on a intérêt
reste encore brillé mais pas ce que je
vais vous dire une chose c'est que cette
affaire le crise sanitaire
elle a montré qu'il existait quoi qu'on
dise une collaboration internationale
c'est la première fois en effet qu'on a
la connaissance international de
l'identité du virus c'est la première
fois que l'on pas très vite
c'est la première fois que dans tous les
pays on utilise à peu près on a le on a
fait le même diagnostic et on utilise à
peu près les mêmes méthodes de
redressement et je trouve que ça il n'y
a pas beaucoup de corporations henin qui
collaborent autant que les médecins et
les laboratoires de recherche
actuellement il ne peut pas se passer
quelque chose dans le monde sans que
dans le quart d'heure qui suivent le
monde entier soit au courant le vaccin
on le connaîtra il naîtra soit en france
ou en allemagne peut-être peut-être en
france et en allemagne d'ailleurs en
même temps mais il sera distribué
partout
merci beaucoup un jean marc sylvestre
journaliste éditorialiste économique
d'avoir été avec nous